all right i have some dr oz giga cringe
for you today this is uh i i have never
seen anything like this this is maybe
the most awkward moment from any
political rally i've ever seen short of
when trump a few weeks ago tried to kiss
that swimmer and she kind of like just
tried to get away from um mehmet oz is a
television doctor and of course as we
spoke about earlier and as as we have
been speaking about he's running in
pennsylvania for the senate he's the
republican nominee his opponent is john
fetterman i would suggest voting for
john fetterman i think fetterman is a
better candidate and um
there was a guy who wanted to ask oz
about abortion
and dr oz puts
straps a blood pressure cuff to the guy
and i don't think i've ever seen
anything this bizarre take a look at
this tell me a little bit about
so awkward
abortion
yes
you know while i take your blood
pressure i will answer that question sir
wow
you know is there a limit to it is there
a you know a time when
women should be allowed to get an
abortion or is it this is an issue that
really affects this man significantly
you can tell should we ban it all
together
and so
so
as you all probably know i'm pro-life
but i have three exceptions and i spoke
about them a lot in the primary i'm a
doctor i appreciate the realities of
taking care of people who are struggling
don't get nervous
so um so i think the life of the mother
rape incest these are
problems that i think families should
have the ability to deal with and it's
hard to expect the government to deal
with
yeah
what in god's name is happening in this
country folks if fetterman doesn't win
this one
i might have to end the show and leave
the political world and just kind of go
out into the woods and just live some
kind of primitive life because i mean
and actually if oz or herschel walker
win i'm going to need to go and have a
deep think
about my life
beyond just being bizarre
what doctor takes blood pressure when
someone's legs are crossed and they're
talking and while they're holding their
arm up in the air i mean it just it's
terrible blood pressure technique wasn't
he a cardiac surgeon he should know this
stuff um and politically here's another
very strange moment from the same rally
where oz compares
homeless people to zombies with needles
sticking out of their necks and you can
just tell he would be an empathetic
senator can't you go down to downtown
philadelphia i see a little bit in
pittsburgh now too but more in
philadelphia i seen it there are whole
blocks i mean like multiple blocks of
areas you can't go there are addicts
walking like zombies you know into the
streets with needles sticking out of
their necks really just
vivid imagery there from mehmet oz this
guy is horrible i mean truly truly
horrible and he has no business being in
the united states senate if you look at
people currently running
are there i mean
i would say any random school teacher
would be
better for the country
as one of the 100 members of the united
states senate than mehmet oz or herschel
walker these seem like two of the worst
people just not worst candidates just if
you said to me david who would be bad
people to be in the senate i would say
well herschel walker would be terrible
and mehmet oz would be terrible to be in
this these people shouldn't be anywhere
near the senate and yet
they could end up collectively making up
two percent right one fiftieth of the
senate let's hope that that doesn't
happen